hi everyone
this is itcs 2021 talk on majorizing
measures for the optimizer
i'm makran and this is joint work with
sander post
danielle ledouche and neil olver
the central object of this talk will be
gaussian processes
a gaussian process is a collection of
gaussian random variables we will assume
that they are centered that they are
mean zero
and they are indexed by a subset x in
rd i will also call this set x
the index set throughout the stock
and the central protagonist of the stock
will be the expected supremum of this
process
which is the expected value of the
supremum of any of these random
variables
let's look at some simple examples to
make it more concrete
suppose x is a set of extreme points of
a polyslope in the dimensions
and zx is given by taking a standard
gaussian in our d
and taking its inner product with each
point in x
the expected supremum of this process is
also called the gaussian width of this
point set x
and it is very useful in dimensionality
reductions mathematics
statistics and so on and we will see
some applications later in this talk
another example comes from random matrix
theory suppose a is a gaussian random
matrix
so that each entry of the matrix is
independent gaussian
and x is the set of all points with
euclidean norm 1.
and suppose the process is given by this
quadratic form x
ax in this case the expected supremum of
this process
is the expected operator norm of a and
this has been very well studied in
random matrix theory
so from these applications it should be
clear that gaussian processes are very
natural
and they have tons of applications in
machine learning mathematics computer
science
statistics and so on
so let's look at one particular example
that will be relevant for us also
which is dimensionality reduction and
here a very powerful result of gordon
says the following
suppose x is a subset of the unit sphere
in the dimension
then there is a projection matrix that
reduces the dimensionality from d
to m dimensions where m is the gaussian
width
square and it preserves approximately
all norms
in the set x so this
theorem is very powerful and it's very
useful in dimensionality reduction
compressed sensing and so on
and in particular it generalizes the
well-known johnson and restaurants leba
which probably most of you have seen
where m is taken to the log of the
cardinality of the set
and one can show that gaussian width is
always bounded by square root of the
log of the cardinality of the set we
will also see
this later in the stock so this gives a
powerful generalization of
johnson linder styles
given this one can ask how can we prove
bounce on the expected supremum of a
gaussian process
so very nice characterization of this
was given by sudhakov
who showed that it is uniquely
characterized by the following distance
metric defined on the set x so
the distance is given by the standard
deviation of the random variable zx
minus zy
and for example in this very special
case
of this gaussian process given by a
point set
this metric is exactly the euclidean
metric
but this need not be the case in general
so now we know that
this metric completely characterizes the
expected supremum
so one can ask what properties of this
metric space gives us upper and lower
bound on the expected supremum
so let's first look at some lower bounds
so one can see that the expected
supremum
is lower bounded by the expected
absolute value of the difference z
x minus z by and this just follows from
symmetry around zero
and this holds for any points x and y
and x
and z x minus z y is a gaussian with
variance
distance squared so in particular this
gives us that the expected supremum
is load bounded by the diameter of x by
taking
two points x and y with maximal distance
in x
so this gives us a very simple lower
bound
and here we only chose two points but
one can ask if we chose many points in
our point set
then can we strengthen this lower bound
and it turns out that this can be
done in particular the expected supremum
is lower bounded by
the supremum overall scales epsilon
and times the square root of the log of
the cardinality of the
minimum epsilon net of x and by epsilon
net i mean that
minimum size of a subset of x where
every point of x is within a distance
epsilon
in this metric from each point in the
net
so in particular if we take epsilon to
be the diameter
then the cardinality of the set is
exactly two and we get the previous
mount
but this bound can be much much better
in some cases
so now we have a lower bound in terms of
the cardinality
of the minimum epsilon net so what about
an upper bound
so let us assume for simplicity that
zero is in the convex cell of our point
set
and our set lifts inside the unit
euclidean fall
so in this case the expected supremum
can be upper bounded by the square root
log of the cardinality of the set and
this just follows from union bound over
x points
and using the gaussian tail bound of e
to the minus t square
over two
and one can strengthen this bound and
this was very influential result of
dudley
by using a technique called chaining and
that we showed that
the upper bound can be replaced by
integral from zero to infinity over all
scales epsilon
the square root log of the cardinality
of the
minimum epsilon net at that scale
and it will be very useful for us to see
how this works
so let me give you a short proof of this
so let us consider the following layer 3
on our point set x the root of this tree
is the origin
the kth layer of this tree is an epsilon
net of x where epsilon is 2 to the minus
k
and we add an edge between a point y and
a point x in the previous layer
if they are nearest neighbors to each
other and we choose
exactly one such point so in particular
the distance between x and y will be two
to the minus k
if i is in the kth layer so with this
tree now we can prove
dudley's upper bound
so the basic idea is we write our random
variable z x
as a telescopic sum of z x i minus z x i
minus one
along the edges of this tree so in
particular x k is the point
x and x zero is zero so this exactly
gives us z
z x and we know that z x minus z x
i is a gaussian with variance to the
minus i squared
for every edge so now just by taking a
union bound over all the edges of a
single layer
as before we get that the expected
maximum value obtained by
any of these random variables z x i
minus the x i minus 1
is at most true to the minus i times
square root log
of the cardinality of the layer i
and this 2 to the minus i comes because
of the standard deviation
and in particular i'm summing this over
all the layers
and using linearity of expectation we
get that the expected submission
is upper bounded by summation of 2 to
the minus i times
square root log of cardinality of ni
and this is essentially at least bound
because
this is just a discretization of the
integral and one can show that they are
only constant factor away from each
other so we have proved dudley's upper
amount so this tree that we just saw
is a special case of what we call a
chaining tree so i'm not going to define
this in general but i will keep
referring to it throughout this talk
so it will be helpful to keep this
example in mind
and in the general case you need to
assign edge probabilities and lengths to
each edges
so that it works with the union bound
so now we can come to majorizing
measures
so we saw this lower bound unexpected
supremum in terms of
the cardinality of the epsilon net with
a single scale
and we saw this upper bound that was
proved by chaining
it turns out that both of these bonds
are not tight the gap can be
arbitrarily large so
motivated by this fornic proved a better
upper bound
which is called the measurizing measures
mount so he showed that
the expected supremum is upper bounded
by the infimum overall probability
measures mu
the supremum overall point in the set
and now again
there's a similar looking quantity as
dudley's bound but
instead of the integral from zero to
infinity square root log of the
cardinality of the
minimum epsilon net here there's a root
log of 1 over the probability measure
of a ball of radius epsilon around x
so this might look strange at first but
the indication behind measurizing
measures is actually very natural
so in particular in dudley's proof that
we just saw all the vertices in each
layer of the chaining tree
they were exactly the same
but you could consider putting weights
on them so that some vertices are more
important
than others
and this is exactly what majorizing
measures tries to do
so in particular if the ball of radius
epsilon around x has very large mass
then that point x should be more
important
and in the end you just choose the best
possible probability measure that you
can choose
so this is the intuition behind majority
measures
so for neat conjecture that this upper
bound was tied
and this was proven by telegram in a
very influential result
that's now called the majorizing
measures theorem
so telegram showed that this majorizing
measures bound they started up to
constant factors
so majorizing measures in fact
characterize the expected supreme
mammogram processes
the original proof of this theorem was
considered very difficult
and the key insight of solid ground was
a notion that was dual to
chaining trees to telegram developed a
notion of
what we call a packing tree so they give
lower bounds and expected supremum just
as straining trees gave upper bounds
and since this theorem is very very
important over the years many simpler
and different proofs have been found
mostly by telegram but also by other
people and in this talk we will also
give
yet another proof of this theorem that
we will see pretty soon
so before we do that it will be very
helpful to look at what packing trees
are
and why they give a lower bound on
expected supremum
so the nodes of a packing tree are
subsets of our index set x
and each child of a node is also subset
of the node itself
so assuming that the diameter of our
index set is one
we require that the diameter of h known
in the tree goes down
exponentially with the depth so it's
bounded by one over two times that depth
and we also require that the children of
any vertex are separated in this tree so
in particular for any
child cicj their distance must be at
least one over ten times the depth of
its parent plus one
so essentially we're trying to pack as
many for
our children as possible in this tree
and let me define the value of first
tree which is a very complicated looking
expression
so let me try to help you parse it so
this is the minimum
over all paths in the tree the first
quantity here is just the diameter of
that particular node along the path
and the second quantity is square root
log of 1 over the number of children
of v
so why do packing trees give a lower
bound on expected supremum
this is due to the sudoku of manuration
inequality that was also proven by
telegram
so telegram showed that the expected
supremum over
v is at least 1 over 10 times
the depth of v which is the diameter of
essentially that node v
times square root log of 1 over the
number of children plus minimum expected
supremum
over any children of three
so in particular the first term here is
exactly what that appears in the value
so if you just apply this uh sudha
communication inequality
starting from the root inductively then
you will get all possible terms until
the
leaf and from this it follows that
the value of any packing tree is a lower
bound than the expected supremum
of the process and we also saw that the
expected supremum is
upper bounded by the value of any
chaining tree
and let me define this quantity gamma 2
which is
just the majorizing measures bound and
essentially the minimum value of a
chaining tree
so the expected supremum is lower
bounded by
packing tree and upper bounded by gamma
2 over the value for chaining tree
and the key inside of telegram or
from this majorizing measures theorem is
that the maximum value for packing tree
is exactly equal up to constant factor
to the minimum value of a chaining tree
so there is some kind of strong duality
between chaining and packing trees
and this basic statement this is not
very obvious in previous proofs
so for example in telegram's original
proof he proved that there is a packing
tree
whose value is lower bounded by gamma 2
which implies the statement
in a later proof it showed that there is
a chaining tree
which gives a lower bound on the value
of the process which also implies the
statement
so in both of in these proofs what is
what belongs to the process and what
belongs to the metrics are
entangled in complicated ways so
now we can revisit majorizing measures
theorem as follows
so we can break it down into two parts
the first part says that the value of
the expected supremum
is lower and upper bounded by chaining
and packing trees
and the second part is that the maximum
value of a
packing tree is same as the minimum
value of a chaining tree
so there is a combinatorial main max
theorem of strong duality
for the underlying metric space between
chaining and packing trees
and the measurizing measures theorem is
just the consequence of these two
statements so in particular this way of
formulating this it separates the role
of metric
from the gaussian processes
and now i can describe what our main
contribution is
we give a new constructive proof of this
combinatorial min-max theorem
using convex duality and rounding
and our main insight is that this strong
duality between chaining and packing
trees
this in fact stems from a convex program
that looks in the background so this is
in fact a consequence of convex duality
so in particular our proof works
completely in the setting of
metric spaces so before i can say more
about the proof
let me first try to give you some nice
applications
so since we can solve a convex program
and do some rounding this gives us
deterministic polynomial time algorithms
for computing various different things
so in particular we can compute optimal
chaining back entries label their
advancement nets
in different state polynomial time this
also gives us yet another way of
computing
cover times of random walks this was
already shown by the
paris and this
gives us a way to compute the projection
matrix in gordon's theorem
so this requires uh deterministic
construction of optimal admissible nets
and builds on a previous work of the
douche guzman and olwa
and a chaining-based proof of oyama
crack then sultan kotabi
so let me try to say a little bit
more about where the convexity comes in
so let's look at this gamma 2 functional
which is just the majorizing measure
small
so this is essentially a convex program
because root log 1 over p
is a convex function when p is between 0
and 1 over e
so now there is a technicality that the
measure can take value between 0 and 1
but this is just the technicality that i
will show you how to fix in a second
so now a primal measure mu that is
solution to this program you can round
it to chaining trees
and in particular this was already shown
by telegram
in 2001 in his majorizing measures
without measures paper
that introduced the concept of generic
chaining
we showed that this rounding can be done
in nearly linear time
which is x square since you need to
specify all pairwise distances for an
arbitrary metric space
so now we show that any dual measure for
a simplified dual
it can be rounded to a packing tree
again very fast in nearly linear time
and just by a consequence of convex
duality
we get that the maximum value of a
backing tree and minimum value for
chaining tree
they are equal up to constant factors
as a final remark let me mention that
rounding is in fact the hard part of
this proof
going from trees to measures is very
easy for example if you have a packing
tree
if you just take each children
uniformly at random and keep doing this
until we hit a leaf
the probability measure that is induced
on the leaves this exactly gives you the
value that is achieved by the dual
so in fact we are doing the hard
direction by rounding
a measure to a tree here
so let me tell you now how to fix this
uh
annoying technical issue that this is
not a convex program exactly
so for this let me replace the root log
one over
t with another function h
and one has to remember that root log
one over p was just the approximation of
the gaussian tail
where we use the simple tail bound of e
to the minus t square
but instead of that one can use the
gaussian tail itself
so one can define h of p
to be the minimum x such that the
probability mass of the gaussian tail
is exactly p at that point
this function is convex and decreasing
on the whole interval 0 to 1.
so this fixes this annoying issue
and now one can work with this more
general
uh function comma h which is 1 x
and in particular if one replaces the
gaussian random variable g with a
arbitrary symmetric clock concave random
variable
uh everything in our proof still works
so this works for a more general
plus of density than just gaussians
okay so now we have our convex program
which is the primal
and let me define a very similar looking
dual
and this is not the real dual because
this is not even concave or convex
but here new is supposed to be another
probability measure
and i've swapped the maximum minimum
here
so in the main result of our paper
is that the value of this primal and
doesn't simplify dual
they can be at most a factor of two
apart ignoring some additive factors of
diameters of x
and this also answers the question of
and nara who showed the same relation
but with a fairly large constant but
they did not rely on conflictuality
and the proof was fairly complicated
whereas our
is quite simple
okay and now one can get primal and dual
batteries just by solving
a convex optimization problem and some
simple greedy algorithm
and then to get optimal chaining and
packing trees you can just apply some
rounding algorithms which
i will tell you about later to get
chaining and packing trees
and this gives a constructive way to
prove the majorising measures theorem
so the rest of this talk i will tell you
the main ideas
involved improving the ski lemma
in particular the first step is
to notice that instead of the maximum
over all points in x
one can again replace it maximum over
all probability measures new
when use a different measure now since
this does not change the value
this one can do because you're
optimizing over the same convex hull
essentially
and now one can swap the main and
maximum there to get the real dual
and convex duality implies that the
value of
this dual is the same as the value of
the primal
so now this tool looks much more
complicated because there are two
different probability measures
mu and nu but one can ask what happens
what's the minimizer mu look like there
in particular what happens
if one sets mu to be the outer measure
nu
if one does that one gets another
optimization problem that we call the
entropic dual
and in particular since we
substituted mu to be nu the value of
this
entropic dual is at least the value are
real dual
but we show that this cannot be
more than a factor two apart actually
some additive factors
and the last step is to reduce uh this
entropic dual to simplify dual
and here the only difference is the the
bottom
most dual doesn't have the expectation
but instead a minimum
and again one direction is clear the
minimum is at most expectation
but we also show that replacing the
expectation with the minimum doesn't
change the value too much
up to a constant factor of the diameter
so altogether the sequence of
simplifications
last two sort of implies that the
value of the real dual and the value of
the simplified dual at the bottom it can
at most be a factor two apart
and by convex duality the value of the
primal is the same as the value of the
dual so we get our key lamp
so now let me
say a few words about how to prove this
very nice approximate duality statement
that setting mu to be new there in that
real dual does not cause too much error
in particular we are going to show that
for any outer measure nu
if we take mu to be new then the value
can differ by a factor of
at most two so the left hand side here
exactly gives you the value of the
entropic dual
and the right hand side gives you the
value of the actual dual
and this statement this claim still
involves an integration over
scales epsilon and we are going to even
fix the scale epsilon
and on the left hand side look at a wall
of radius 2 epsilon
and on the right hand side look up or
look at the ball of radius epsilon
and show that these values differ by a
constant additive factor and if you
integrate over here scales epsilon
and do a substitution of 2 epsilon 2
epsilon
then you record the claim on the top
so to prove this it will be useful to
view this in a graph theoretically
so consider the graph bipartite graph
where the left hand right hand side are
just elements of
x and that is the edge if the distance
between the two points is at most
epsilon
and this is the weighted graph on the
left hand side the weights are given by
nu and on the right hand the weights are
given by mu
now if you consider a point x on the
left hand side
its neighborhood on the right is exactly
the ball of radius epsilon
and its two hop neighborhood is exactly
the ball of radius 2 epsilon
and essentially what we want to show is
that transporting
the mass from one to two hop
neighborhood it doesn't incur too much
cost so in particular
let us consider a very special case
suppose it happens that for every subset
a on the right
its new measure is always smaller than
the new measure of its neighborhood
and this is exactly hall's condition and
this is saying that there is a
fractional perfect matching
between mu and nu so essentially we can
match
with all the probability mass of mu and
nu
in this case the proof should be very
simple i mean you justified and multiply
by the same quantity
and we just use the very basic property
of this function h
that it's sub-multiplicative and if you
just use that
this ratio is at least one by our
assumption so
just using sub multiplicatively gives us
that this is bounded by this
quantity and this is essentially the
claim
and h of one is even zero
by our assumption so this gives us the
claim in this
very special case and in general
if this is not true and
if there isn't a fraction of perfect
matching then we cannot match an entire
probability mass but we can still match
some beta fraction of the mass where
beta is less than one
and now the basic idea is we just do
this
remove the maximal blocking set and keep
repeating this process
and in the end one can show that
you essentially incur a cost which is
given by a maximum over
the unit interval of some quantity
related to h
that we can bound by constant
so this is essentially the proof of
approximate duality so
this proves the first statement
so for the next statement where we
replace
the expectation with the minimum to get
to the final simplified dual
i'm not going to go too much into it but
the basic idea is very simple
one just iteratively removes the values
where minimum is much smaller than
expectation
and then replaces the original property
measure with the condition distribution
and one can show that this gives you
another dual measure
uh where the value of these two things
are very close to each other
so this proves this approximate duality
statement
and now one has a way
to find these travel and dual measures
just by solving this
optimization problem and by simple
conditioning
that can be done using a simple greedy
algorithm
and this gives a way
to compute optimal chaining and pack
increase by rounding
so let me say a few words about rounding
also just to give you some idea of how
it's done
so again the rounding is done by a
procedure called revolt partitioning
that was
introduced by telegram so procedure is
very simple
on our intuitive level so this is our
index at x
you just repeat the following until we
exhaust all the points of x
we take the measure of a ball of a given
radius
we remove the ball of a larger radius
and we do this again
and we keep doing this until we exhaust
the whole set x
and it's not important that we are
maximizing measure over balls you can
consider variants where you
instead of balls you replace them with
intersected balls
instead of measures here you can
maximize some other potential or
functionals over your space
but basically idea is this
and then we recurse and geometrically
decrease the small
so this is the basic greedy ball
partitioning and the previous
rounding to packing trees
this was based on a variant of this
greedy bulb partitioning so in
particular
there one does not run from measures one
needs some functionals
that satisfy certain property and
instead of maximizing measures or
the value of the function over balls you
look at intersected balls
so this is a little bit asymmetric
compared to the primal rounding
where one just maximizes the measures
over balls in a very simple way
and also because of the intersection
it's difficult to implement this in
near linear time so our main
contribution is that
we show that greedy partitioning if one
uses primal and dual measures
it gives you a chaining and packing
trees in a fairly symmetric way
and in near linear time so in particular
given an input measured row
we can get chaining and packing trees
that achieve the value obtained by the
corresponding
primal and dual programs
and also the
algorithm is fairly symmetric in
particular
the induced partition that is given by
the by the outer balls
in this gradible partitioning this gives
us a variant of chain entry
and the inner balls which are already
separated
a large subset of them gives a packing
tree
of course i'm simplifying a lot of
details here and the analysis is still
quite subtle and involved
but at least this makes the primal and
dual side fairly symmetric
so let me summarize and conclude with
some open problems so we gave a new
constructive proof of the combinatorial
min max core of the majorizing measure
theorem
using convex duality and rounding we
showed that the value of the primal and
the simplified dual
i post the factor two apart one can
round these to find optimal chaining and
packing trees
so the most costly part of this current
picture
is finding these measures for now we
just
rely on a black box solver to solve
these optimization problems
and the runtime depends on rectangular
matrix multiplication
but even if you can do it optimally it's
probably
hard to do it in a general way in
near linear time
but since we want to solve a specific
economics program
and we really need a crude additive
approximation
we can hope that you can still do it in
nearly in time
even finding the primal and dual
measures
and the second thing is jenny has
various algorithmic applications and
other one can find using this convex
optimization paradigm some other
algorithmic applications of this
approach
so that's it thank you very much